president biden's first news conference
turning into a total catastrophe but
don't just take our word for it just
look at what the white house was forced
to do
they had to roll out a cleanup crew in
order to mop up one biden blunder after
the other like when the president
claimed the midterm elections may be
stolen
well it all depends on
[Music]
whether or not
we're able to
make
the case to the american people that
some of this is being set up to try to
alter the outcome of the election the
increase in the prospect of being
illegitimate is a direct proportion of
us not being able to get these
these reforms passed
the white house trying to backtrack and
is claiming that it's not what the
president actually said dana p asked
press secretary jensachi exactly what
biden meant listen
i'm curious if he will continue to say
that those 2022 elections will be
illegitimate
well first i've talked to the president
a lot about this and he absolutely is
not predicting
that the 2022 elections would be
illegitimate the point he was raising
was both that in 2020 even amongst
challenging circumstances efforts to
suppress the vote and and the midst of a
pandemic there was record turnout he was
not making a prediction he has
confidence in the american people and
we're going to do everything we can to
protect people's rights
kamala harris also being rolled out for
mop up duty but in true kamala harris
fashion she actually made things worse
by refusing to answer a simple question
the bills were debated and they didn't
pass
but the specific question if you don't
mind
does he think now that these bills
haven't been passed that the 22
midterms won't be legitimate or fair or
free
let's not conflate issues
dana let's not conflate issues
i don't know
what
issues
they've even agreed upon
it seems like everyone's saying
something different at the white house
well one thing that's pretty interesting
is that savannah guthrie over at the
today show that was her first question
too right it's like what did he mean
when he said the elections will be
illegitimate are you saying
that
what the what president trump said about
2020 which you disavowed because you say
that the 2020 election was legitimate
good okay fine let's we let's maybe i'll
try to agree on that or some agree on
that i agree with that
well then are you saying that this next
one is not going to be because what what
are the specifics they've never laid
that out
and so then you have the press secretary
have to come out and say actually no
what he was saying is this and i can't
remember what her tweet said but i can
imagine that the white house
communications team as soon as he said
that thought okay that's there's one
thing that we're going to have to do
right away that issue is not going to go
away because it wasn't just kamala
harris that said what she said
congressman jim clyburn of south
carolina said it as well
so get ready buckle up everybody we're
gonna have a big fight again about
legitimacy of elections without
specifics of concern
um
they are exp the democrats are expected
to lose big time
a lot of seats in this midterm election
and not just in the midterm for congress
but we're talking about state houses
state races things like that so
are they democrats trying to set it up
that if they lose those elections aren't
legitimate where have we heard that
before
and where did that really like screw
things up for everybody okay so there
was that there's just one other thing i
think the um
mop up that
was a pretty big deal
and that was the minor incursions are uh
going to possibly be okay now uh by the
biden administration
excuse me last night they had to have a
national security official i think was
probably jake sullivan get on the phone
and tell everybody actually that's not
what he meant
but that is exactly what our adversaries
and our allies heard and you saw
zielinski put out a no note today
they're trying to walk it back that was
a big blunder
and the media uh kind of agrees with us
greg listen to the mainstream press just
dissect this press conference
if you're foggy and meandering on key
questions and you're also not winning
then you've got a real problem putin and
she and our nato allies are not debating
that right now they see joe biden as
weak yesterday's press conference did
not help so uh i didn't think it was a
very impressive list and i'd probably go
back to the drawing board i'm not sure
that his staff is
exactly excited about all the news he
made no there's a lot to clean up
what do you think greg
well first off i have to say that i look
great in this studio
anyway yeah you thought the exxon valdez
needed to clean up joe was like hey hold
my insurer uh i'm going to use a booze
analogy
you got to compare every we're in this
state where we kind of we always have to
compare joe biden to the guy before him
right and j and trump is kind of like
was an everyday presence so we built up
a tolerance and he'd come out and he'd
speak he was like a nightly martini we
got used to it but biden he's like a guy
you he didn't drink for a year and then
he comes out and he binges for two hours
and now we all have we all have a biden
hangover i mean i'm as confused as i am
after that happened i think the big
mistake was
he they thought going it going long
going along would address the questions
of mental fitness but instead it
revealed the fogginess as van jones
pointed out the confusion and also the
crankiness that came later that you
pointed out uh it's like again i mean
another analogy it's like a classic car
that's been sitting in the garage you
don't immediately drive it across the
state you know you drive it down to the
diner five miles down the road that's
joe's speed but i always i got to defend
him it's not his fault i mean he
he didn't make himself president the
democratic party did it's 2022 and i
still can't believe joe biden's
president he's been around my entire
lifetime and he's president now after
running i don't know 13 times the bottom
line though
if there was very little time spent on
american concerns it was spent on media
concerns and that was the bogus voting
bill in russia meanwhile americans just
wanted to hear about law and order
getting food on their table it's like
they order steak and the democrats keep
delivering them tofu yeah geraldo no
questions on the border
but a lot of questions about the border
on ukraine what did we get like a dozen
questions about that it just seems like
way off by the press
well i think the uh the criticism is a
bit harsh of the president i thought it
wasn't that bad he did make that awful
blunder about the minor incursion in
ukraine which kind of made the hair in
the back of my neck stand up uh you know
and and some of his other language i was
uh was
kind of uh meandering i do agree with
that but i also think that he showed
incredible stamina for an old guy i
admired the fact that he was on his feet
for two hours answering some very
hostile questions including some
one from our former colleague james
rosen
that was so insulting
he asked
the president united states you know uh
you know are are you uh are you mentally
incapable of holding your office i mean
can you imagine james rosen or anyone
else asking ronald reagan that i thought
that was very very rude
you know he cleaned up uh the ukraine i
think that the the good thing about the
ukraine is that he made it clear that he
wasn't drawing a red line that we
weren't committing ourselves to a war in
europe if there was a further ukrainian
incursion by the russians thank god for
that because there's so many hawks in
washington i could just see them all
beating the drums come on let's send the
101st airborne the 82nd airborne to uh
to ukraine right now i'm glad that he
didn't go that far
what he did do was unfortunate and i
think it was uh it was a slip because
not because it was false but because i
believe it was true i think that there
is u.s policy that if there is a minor
incursion they're not going to go
nuclear in terms of the sanctions but
you know that's you shouldn't think out
loud especially in that context jesse
that's a pretty low bar to geraldo's
point katie that he stood up for a long
time
i mean come on geraldo
in 78 days
well first of all the question about
mental acuity was asked because half of
the country including a number of
independents in the latest ap poll have
very serious concerns about joe biden's
mental ability to hold the job so the
question being asked was just a
reflection of what people are saying to
people calling them on the phone and
asking about the president and the job
that he's doing
but when it comes to the press
conference yesterday they rolled out
everybody they rolled out nancy pelosi
as we said the vice president and
everybody had a problem and wasn't on
the same page with exactly what they
were saying and what the message was in
terms of what they said today jenn saki
said during the press briefing that
foreign leaders are happy and that a
person who respects democracy and
alliances is back in the white house
well then you touch on the two issues
that were the main problems yesterday in
the press conference domestically the
president is now questioning
the democracy and the legitimacy
legitimacy of elections and in foreign
policy our alliances are
all over the place europe nato don't
know what they're going to do if ukraine
is invaded the ukrainians are very
worried about what the united states is
or isn't going to do and the bottom line
is there's been no deterrence this
didn't happen to president trump because
there was deterrence and
putin sees an opening here to do
something and also the last thing is
that because they waited so long to roll
joe biden out to the public 78 days
since the last
press conference he had no wins to talk
about they they had him out there after
he lost everything there was nothing
that he won on they could have put him
out a month ago before these bills were
voted on and maybe get ahead of it they
didn't do that they put him out there
after he had nothing to go on and when
he was a lame duck and that's why all
the questions yesterday had very tough
answers yeah now before we go geraldo um
is that your front lawn you're standing
in right there
yes it is it is it's quite chilly but i
can take it okay and have you been in
that second floor room over your left
shoulder have you seen that wing of the
house i have not yet visited it but i i
assure you that when you guys go on your
trip to wyoming stop here and we'll
visit it together all right that's a
deal hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else